all right well from divins to fly-ins we
are celebrating eight years of slotzilla
this week rocky is live on fremont
street to learn more about this
adventurous anniversary hey rocky
hey jillian jc jillian you just said
that was a great way to see the city
this is another great way to see the
city and it is very special as the
largest slot machine in the world did i
say that right absolutely 11 stories
high here on fremont street you're
celebrating eight years of slot zilla
here just what does this ride mean to
the city of las vegas i'll tell you it's
an icon of the city of las vegas really
it truly is a bucket list experience
you're traveling 1750 feet up to 35
miles an hour over the original las
vegas strip uh you're flying by you have
concerts going on tens of thousands of
people below you it's really sensory
overload and it's just an absolute blast
and really this ride kind of keeps
downtown fremont street going right it
really does so we do about a half
million riders annually uh this allows
us the revenue generator from slotzilla
allows us to reinvest in the street
right so all our free concerts downtown
rocks concert series new year the the st
patrick's days of the world the
halloweens of the world are just an
amazing thing that is all really truly
funded by this core revenue generator
wow well that is so vegas of all of you
here you have to come down and celebrate
eight years whether you're a local or a
tourist i think we're seeing a couple
tourists getting suited up right now and
before this an 80 year old woman was up
here by herself ready to take the ride
what does that mean to you to have these
people coming in it truly is special
it's really everyone from really a
teenager to an 80 year old person just
have an absolute time
it's really all about living life right
uh and as you're kind of flying through
that ear that everything that the
surrounding environment is just truly
fun magical and a great las vegas
experience definitely and speaking of
teenagers our elders whoever you're also
invited down to work for slovzilla last
time i was here it was the fly and apply
where you were flying or you were flying
on the zipline to go ahead and accept
your job here at slotzilla so tell us
about your team that's so special to you
guys i'll tell you it's just a fun
environment right can you imagine going
to work at the largest most successful
urban based thrill ride in the world and
that's your job right and so we actually
ironically have uh need for uh for ride
operators uh which is like i said it's
just a great fun family oriented
environments i know you get to fly for
free as well so there's nothing no
downside to that well thank you so much
happy eighth anniversary to slotzilla
we're about to go up one more story to
really see the vantage point the
viewpoint that you get when you go out
and take off so stay tuned for that
we'll be right back thank you rocky
hopefully we'll see her get on the
zipline